[Music]
one of the most important attributes of
origami is once we have studied and
understood the way paper folds and
unfolds we can apply those patterns to
things that are very different from
paper I hope by bringing the tools of
mathematics into my origami design that
I can then fold something that's
beautiful and that's unexpected my name
is Robert Lang and I'm a physicist and
an origami artist
origami is the Japanese name for the art
of folded paper and most origami is
folded from a single sheet of paper with
no cuts or tears I have loved origami
entire life I pursued it ever since I
was a kid but my study was science and
engineering I worked for NASA doing
research on lasers but throughout that
whole time I had been pursuing origami
developing designs writing books so in
2001 I quit my job to try to make a
career out of origami
I've worked on a couple of different
folding patterns that were round and
would wrap into a cylindrical geometry
to fit into a rocket and I developed an
airbag in a car that inflates from a
small folded bundle so whenever an
engineer creates something that opens
and closes in a controlled way they can
make use of the folding patterns of
origami over the years math has allowed
me to realize as an artist shapes and
creations that I couldn't achieve any
other way
traditional origami was relatively
simple
the designs would have taken maybe 20 or
30 steps at most but today origami
pieces can be so complicated
that they can have tens hundreds maybe
even a thousand steps when I'm folding
that's like working with an old friend
it's like dancing with a partner whose
moves I know if I move this way I know
my partner is going to move that way and
so I explore the math develop the
equation solve the equations create the
folding pattern and then I find out what
it looks like and as often as not it is
beautiful
for me the driving force is that there's
always something new to try a new
problem a new subject a new shape that I
didn't think I was able to create before
but now I think I know how to realize it
and each time I saw the problem you get
this wonderful feeling and you want more
of those feelings
[Music]
my love of kites started about 20 years
ago I talked math 235 years I just
combine the two to try to reach all of
my students I figured why not take this
whole math lesson outside maybe just
maybe they would see the relationship
[Music]
my name is Winfred Randolph lo but in
delray on the beach when I'm flying my
dives
they call me Randy the country I started
flying kite 20 years ago
I bought my first crab and I never
looked back I fly my cards as much as
possible I have about 60 or 70 turns on
any particular given day you can paint
the sky with sea creatures whales scuba
divers you're not only looking at the
kite but you're looking at the strings
there's math there then you can do
something with it
cakes are geometric figures kites are
triangles and that is one of the things
that I tried to take advantage of
instead of doing it in a classroom your
desk would take them on the field
Pythagorean theorem is a formula used to
determine sides of triangles who want to
use that in theorem on the beach as
we're trying to fly a kite and let the
kite go and it travels up the line
better known as the hypotenuse if we
draw a line from the top of the cake
down to the bottom that's side a if we
draw another line from that point back
to where we let the kite go
that would be side B so by plugging
those numbers into the triangle we have
just figured out how long I'll string
this and where we are standing to the
top of the kite
patience we could do fractions common
denominators uncommon to them more
complicated the numbers are the more
masterís I retired six years ago we get
a lot of families to come on Delray
Beach and they have kids and I teach
math I don't see that right there we
could do a math problem like that you
know and some kids understand oh yeah we
did that in the school nowadays they see
it but for the lot of the younger kids
get some thinking too
[Music]
[Music]
an engineer in our society they they
don't look like me but I'm here to break
that mold my name is Daisy mo Williams
and it's kind of hard to explain but I
don't worry deja deja is a manufacturing
engineer at NASA's Jet Propulsion lab
and she's also a musician
Wilson I literally couldn't have said it
better myself
Thank You deja let's get back to where
it all started JJ's love of science all
began when she was growing up in st.
Louis I grew up on the south side of st.
Louis Missouri in a single-parent
household with my mom I got into science
because of a program that my mom kicked
down doors to give me in to they expose
us to different science topics such as
robotics chemistry you name it in
college they just studied engineering
management while there she faced more
than just challenging schoolwork a lot
of times in class I was the only female
I was the only black female sometimes
people didn't want to sit by you
sometimes people didn't want to help you
you know I will see a lot of times that
people will have their how I'm trying
not to cry people will have their little
groups that they were studying with and
I would have to like infiltrate like how
can I bond with that group so that I can
get the same resources that my people
don't have when I figured it out of
course she figured it out which brings
us to NASA deja is part of a team
building rocket ships they take an
engineer's idea and figure out how to
make it a reality which is pretty
freakin cool now remember a minute ago
when we mentioned that deja was also a
musician she wrote a song about science
to the tune of soldier boys crank that
I'm just right now I'm like yo this is
hot X equals in this old negative be
lesser motor square root of b squared
minus 4ac first I'm not fine
but hey rude over to a rude over to hey
hey Dasia realized that through music
you can open up a whole new audiences
eyes to the world of science something
she wished she had when she was young
but it's not just writing a song and
that's it like actually take it a step
further and am a mentor to a lot of
students who either interested in
science or already in college and just
need that extra push to continue and
finished I want to show through my life
that you can be an engineer you can't be
a musician it oh the sky's the limit
[Music]
one of the newest additions to the
skyline in Hamburg Germany is a concert
hall fit for a modern Mozart
the Elbphilharmonie is considered one of
the largest and most acoustically
advanced concert venues in the world
made up of three concert halls the
Elbphilharmonie seats more than 2,800
visitors the great concert hall the
largest of the three halls has 10,000
unique acoustic panels that were
designed using computer algorithms to
create the best possible sound each
panel contains 1 million cells that
shape the sound by either absorbing the
waves or having them reverberate through
the space the curved design of the cells
can be seen replicated throughout the
entire building not to be outdone the
glass exterior of the Elbphilharmonie
built atop a former warehouse is just as
spectacular as the interior the
structure rises above the L driven
mirrors the water's wave and shine to
mark the opening night the exterior
featured a light show timed to the music
being played within the Great Hall with
multiple events almost every day the
Elbphilharmonie is a must-see for music
and math lovers alike
[Music]
juniper okay say the superior a private
senior are contrary then their IV leader
is not some previously known as possibly
dad hola soy mrs. Vasquez Tango in tcha
aliens avoid class and a facultad de
ciências come my spider-man costume
president is a casa con eldest ferry's
illegal dis pasado
hasta la universidad initial mentor
universidad condo Yaga con este
disfraces todo tipo de acciones mo gente
que mention estas loco pero con el
tiempo sin da da cuenta case
unintentional Nestor yes pathological
tell ya medicinal hombre Tanya de
Ciencias a beast I must a connection con
una una I know that Naruto does connais
displays none other than the Yanomami
Ruslan entry visas yo creo que realmente
nose cough Amma
it is important nokia noises he knob
cases the scene so you say girls comics
los evil agenda a co-op election and oh
this is really saw Selma como spider-man
poor kun da villian elders for the
public college in the comics you know
Navi nieta estaba spider-man freedom
bizarro dunno classic
me hey insert a mocha co-mingled área
que la gente era
Cato's podemos red asada so trabajo
siempre con Oh ay Ana's
en me caso dispersal may my motivo para
ser un mejor profesor pero cada quien
debe encontrar la manera de su trabajo
con mayor felicidad Kamiyama cassian
[Music]